こんにちはドクター始めたいや今日はドクターではないな
今日は妻そんな始めたら勝たせてやっていけそう
スマホ問題果たせ始めたそうそっ実は私
スマホにとても詳しいんですよね11416時間ドレスの放送だってレポスマホに感謝
天才的な知識があるようでございます
あります僕は今までですね下落し
ギャラクシー2て galaxy s 4の3つは今まで使ってきました
そうキャラクターを使っていたという関係でちょっと galaxy s 5とかも
触らせていただいたこともあったんですけども強いですね
なんとなんとですね galaxy s 6そして
galaxy s 6 edge の2種類が
part 2倍されることになりました
ってで galaxy s 6と galaxy s 6 edge の2種類が新た
に販売すればいいの壁付けのはなぜには私ですねデラクシー6と galaxy s 6
edge の丸戸ツアー
まあいわゆるあれですね発表会展 galaxy 立つ発表が呼ばれてずっとね
イベントに参加していただきました
ん
三田市に行ってきましたいただきますじゃあお願いだそうだ
今回は主に galaxy s 6 edge についてちょっと紹介していこうと
思っていますめちゃくちゃ綺麗ですよ見た目がスマホの裏もなんかピカピカしてて
すごい
透明感があってラストメダルを融合した中州コーティング出されてるらしいけど
すっごい綺麗だっなキャラクターし来てちょっとするんですけど
ほとんだろ2以下にグニャってるっていうで強くによって映像への没入感が現れるって
言うのはこう映像を受けて見える感じがしました
そしては一番僕はビックリしたのは映像の綺麗さです
こういう中でも全うされる事例さんというか見てびっくりする
綺麗さでしたガチでたいという感じのデラクシー6 galaxy s 6 edge
のイベントでございました
私がなこのイベントに行って良いと思ったポイントねまぁ3つほどね君たちに教えると
思う今日
まずはポイントは cpu 丸坊主っていうのですよ
もうストゥハンパないっす
よなんですね cpu が8こ
組まれています8子ですよ
あっはぱそこんかってもうパソコンでしょう
cpu 8子を組み込んでいるオクタコアという仕様になっておりますもサクサクです
なので今まで以上にアプリの起動がキュっても超速くて3つ以上アプリを立ち上げて
もうサクサク動くという感じでございますヤバイっしょ
見どころその2見た目がとりあえずかっこいいわけです今回にすごい
クールなイメージでした技術
裏側ねすっごい綺麗な花に生かした女性とかこう思ってそうなイメージでしたポイント
4-3
これはねまさにする時代でございますよなあとエッ
なんとワイヤレスチャージャー機能がありますこれですねバイアルス充電台を使うこと
によってなんとその充電台に置くだけで充電ができちゃうんですよこので全治コードを
させるんじゃなくてこうおくだけ充電がされるっていう
欲しい僕が特に凄いなと元などの3つでございました
あとですねちょっとカメラの起動が0.7秒ツってもうすぐ取れましたです的で実際に
できて1台を兼ねしているので実際に触ってみようと思います
まずカメラ機能がねほんとに便利だと思っておりますオスた瞬間ねぇてないようですよ
このスピードこれならもうねぇハプニング映像とか何かどっするそれかな
めっちゃイラストも綺麗だはいこれ感じでちゃんとね動画もばついてくれます
俺きれいまぁ後は何といっても操作感ですね超早いです起動か
このスピード感
やばいずギャラクシーまで使ってきてるんで結構お礼のいうことはマジだからかなり
ヤバイキスとなっております
というわけでネイチャーラクティス6そして galaxy s 6 h
とてもいいと思います
ています
だけどはぁ
てるよえっ
じゃろっっ
ジャガーを先制 osso しぶりですーエセー
ブーブー s のデザインへへっだーデー
います
def